hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until dawn now we
got some clues here but we already saw
these so I don't think we need to look
at them again I haven't found any more I
pocketed I don't want to get into that
just yet I want to see these things be
your hero Mike came to Jessica's aid
immediately Jessica appreciated Mike's
heroism and I'll just guys probably dead
something for later Sam found a baseball
bat and left it in the cellar so I know
where dad is
I remember that I don't need to know
about that back to this creepy douche
why did you board it up why is there
Gore in a jar
who are you I don't know are you even
talking to a person no I'm kind of
scared right now
people who are afraid are the worst the
worst stuff well emily is quite a fear
of failure yeah the choices you've made
thank you I guess how do you know this
am I still lying to you
okay bye I'll be over here weird Oh
would you respected yourself
I respect personal distance a little bit
of personal space bubble loyalty so you
would tell a lie in order to be loyal to
a friend okay
and what about loyalty versus charity
charity can be fleeting but loyalty is
forever so you would sooner look after
your friends before caring for those in
greater need no that's not what I said
at all you presume a lot these one
minute sessions are the greatest I
honestly don't think I could tolerate
any more also why is there with no
boarded up and why are we turning into a
Transylvanian vampire mansion are you
are you oh I was just playing I was
literally just playing
today is the one-year anniversary of the
dreadful tragedy of Hanna Beth
Washington to the twins who are still
missing I know it would mean so much to
Hannah and Beth that were we're all
still here together and I'm thinking of
them whoa hello somebody's getting a
little friendly boom butterfly effect
excuse me did you say something oh did
you not hear me was your sluttiness stop
it Mike why don't you check out the
guest cabin when I told you about yeah
did you hear that what in God's name are
you wearing here's our one-way ticket to
the spirit rail - watch out for that
Josh that's how it's gonna be okay here
we go to communicate with the spirit
world you must free your mind of all
preconceptions drop all inhibitions and
generally give yourself over entirely to
the will of others sublimating your
every desire the wings of the spirit
master this is so cliche it hurts this
is so cliche shoes hurts a recent
convert oh yeah flippant every day
is anyone there hello I got the phone
spirits
Hey abracadabra um if you can hear my
boys give us a sign
yeah like a peace sign or type sign if
you're not gonna take this serious okay
okay is anyone there
why would we take this seriously in the
first place oh god I know I didn't do
anything it's moving again H what
spelling hold on it's a spoon heck I
swear it's just moving help HP move fast
I don't know what does it mean we need
to know who it is if we're supposed to
help them oh wait wait who needs help
how are you oh here it goes
okay X is T sister sister
her sister oh come on this is for real
shot up
ask your whose sister George it's it's
gotta be yeah okay well which sister is
it then
Ashley asked who it is
who are we speaking to Hanna
is that you
Oh God this is messed up
Josh are you fine are you sure because
we can stop no dude it's cool I want to
hear what it says I don't know where to
start I think that if this is actually
Hannah I mean we can find out what
happened that we're making a lot of
presumptions here Josh um let me think
what happened to you Oh unless she's
vengeful yeah well apologize best to get
on the ghosts good size if you can hear
this like really hear this we all want
to apologize for what happened it was
stupid and and mean and we're sorry
we're so sorry Hannah
B yo
betrayed me it's still going
Oh God hey I
- come come down need to find out more
what do they mean asking what happened
it's the only way to go ask the mash
verify ok ok how did you die
Hannah what happened to you
oh I be the library maybe there's
something in library oh oh
proof there's there's proof holy [ __ ]
Chris
it's [ __ ] this isn't real
Josh I don't know man you're not gonna
believe it now you're not gonna believe
it
no I don't know if you think messing
with me is somehow going to help me deal
with my grief or whatever but this is
not cool Josh no you wanted to use this
beer pour it calm down it's it's not a
mess right now okay full of it should we
go after him
he'll be okay let's it's just give him
some time I don't blame him that was
crazy the pointer flew right off the
table I wasn't faking anything I think
we should do what it says we should look
in the library
Hey we're going off a lot of assumptions
here I know we're just gonna toss the
one who was pushing everyone to do it
that is super suspicious to me that it's
100% straight-up suspicious Josh is a
rogue element here we don't know what
his motivation Jerry we don't know we
don't know if he wants revenge we don't
know if he wants like Barry everyone it
was a part of his sister's death you
know we don't know he could have been
manipulated and pointed him to go into
library and then got upset to get alone
anyway in there buddy
why why
kill you I didn't know you had the cute
little lady leg scream my god well be
witty I still want to get into your
pants
thank you oh is that so yeah looks like
you have to try harder a challenge
you're strapped in you're about to feel
I don't want to feel the full force of
that I'm just gonna be straight up with
the idol I don't want to feel half the
force of that I want to feel full for
something else but not that yellow means
danger yeah no yellows good yellows
guidance who was that she was climbing
back up away are we supposed to go back
we're going back be a good thing
probably
well let's blindly charge forward
because why not
hello any murderers out there anybody
wants to sit like
again with the awkward flirting can't
wait for more of that once we get back
to the cabin can't wait for more a lot
of life well I love living I love to
live life and all of its wonders can't
wait to see my family when we get back
home I may be in high school but I'm
only a few days from retirement
yeah really loud squirrel anyway
mm-hmm it's both my first day on the job
and my last day of retirement no caribou
hello
it did not like that
maybe we didn't need to do anything at
all maybe that was a whole lot of
nothing that should happen there Noel
already done with it might as well keep
going now
yeah blindly charging forward mowing
through every horror cliche known to man
I really do bad to Josh Wow oh my god
yeah yeah what am i doing okay well oh
god yeah Josh some of these lenses are
awfully low resolution aw there goes
sweet revenge the douchey way
oh no she's gonna fall it no no
oh my god yes turnabout is fair play my
good lady I just scared you I didn't so
Hugh I'll do everything in my power not
underestimate my culinary jobs when I
don't know did did probably hurt my
relationship did it do that
yeah I'm not very terrible right now but
I'm very funny that is the best thing oh
that I'm exceptionally funny not
charitable for some reason I'm not that
okay
waiting that why is me and Matt not do
good wait who's mad wait who the hell
was Matt again I have no idea
all right anyway moving right along
anybody up here that needs to announce
themselves before I punch him in the
face mmm I could be making a lot of
inappropriate jokes here but I'm not
gonna
so don't I'm a the game needs to stop
doing that that's not okay
I mean jump scares will jump scare
anybody but the game has been nothing
but those thus far
I wanna know are they banging sex again
that was not sex achill bangin knew what
gave me the clue don't comfort it yeah
be it as much as you want to comfort an
animal it could thrash it could
definitely hurt you
hey I'm gonna make this quick for you
okay
okay I made that one
find a weapon find a marathon no yeah
crazy-fast how pretty sure bears don't
know how to open cabin doors hmm
open car doors what we're on the
internet really okay well this isn't the
Internet Jess right this is real life
where you can buy bear or anything else
I'm gonna open that cabin door
because locked it you're eight okay I'm
almost feeling relaxed again almost this
is not the cozy Chalet I was promised
Mike yeah well there is a fireplace fire
yes it is Michael I am a lady and a lady
needs a proper romantic setting she's a
lady a lady would like to cuddle up with
her man buy a nice cozy fire babe did an
atmospheric mood lighting right it'll
get plenty toasty once we're rubbing up
against each other what are you trying
to insinuate here fire and mood lighting
yes
but me my milady met me made me a lady
mmm lady okay so how do I get this dirty
Hey look it's a light let me slowly grab
it
no I just made it even creepier huh hi
all right we get a good feel for this
yeah that's got a nice texture to it
yeah wait I think it's got a bit not bad
not bad it's good wood it's good primo
would do bad my fingers are broken in
ten places
wait yeah gotta get the right angle on
this just broke the fingers again you
should do I think I saw one over on this
table over here Mike lost your phone
drops outside
you couldn't even get Internet up here
why do you need it ok ok but first we
need to get the fire going I just wish
you hadn't gotten me completely soaking
wet trying to steer me to back into the
dick move I'm sorry Jess probably fill
out the water it doesn't even work
anymore anyway so whatever I'll make it
up to you I promise was that was that
footie steps that was a whole bunch of
footie steps wasn't it
who's gonna fire up some nookie maybe
you never know I want to find a weapon
first before we get to nookie on I'll
pull an epic prank and give her a noogie
instead oh wait let me think about this
one is it's right aggro there we go man
I wish my fingers weren't broken what
are you doing it's the lights I know
it's the lights dummy you broke them no
really faulty wiring or something jeez
I'm trying to be romantic old you could
give me the benefit of the doubt God
what is this over here
who is this
Oh God oh cool
bronze not bad well alrighty then that's
a creepy-ass al wonder what's over here
ha boy the lovely horrible bid I just
need to check some things I need to get
things ready for the romantic moods
don't you know I'm a romantic type of
guy where's my Marvin Gaye oh I don't
know if I wanna do this oh god those
whales are giving me the creeps really
really really really okay time to go
bang up some fires with milady
well first this I'm just gonna shake it
a little bit I guess oh oh hell yeah
uh-huh
nice pun I'm playing a game that's
practically a movie and you're gonna get
it on with the banging and whatnot all
right time to go I guess okay nothing
else in here you just be on my way not
eager anything okay I try the fuse again
blow everything up new key no I'm on my
way my lady pretty to romanticize your
pants right off you ready for some of
this Hey look I did it man what's up
what world is that house fires light
well I I wish we had some booze well if
I'd have known that ahead of time what's
wrong what's wrong baby its home doing
something wrong no I thought you were
one way but you're kinda another way
just that makes sense it's not your
fault
Oh Jess I really like you
whoever you think I am well just give me
a chance and I will show you what you
need
well I am liking your confidence
Mike the shutters
what about them um close them please
it's just the one out there I feel like
someone's watching us I don't like it I
get the same way when I go up into the
middle of the woods he will hurt someone
like
that was some bear sump red beer what's
over here where's this Jack yes no I'm
not gonna hint no God don't point a gun
at anybody ever ever don't point a gun
at anything you're not willing to
destroy okay shudders shudders shudders
shudders shudders [ __ ] you understand
- ow - you're just gonna spin in a
circle she utters cheddar cheddar she
understands shudder and then we're gonna
cut this episode here thank you
everybody so much for watching I know
you guys want to get to the hanky-panky
the world's slowest lead up the world's
slowest lead up to four plate why is my
honesty down what did i do what did i do
why didn't do nothing forgetting -
nothing I'm generous I'm charitable okay
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video